September was a contraction that means
the economy shrunk and on a quarterly
basis that also means we're heading for
a recession if we have another quarter
of negative growth you can see this
quarter's data there that slither of red
means the economy got not 0.2 percent
smaller and that's not a big number on
its own in fact the extra bank holiday
that we had in September could even
explain that small that small
contraction but it does look like the
harbinger of worst to come today's data
particularly led by some disappointing
manufacturing data with manufacturing
output is significantly down quarter on
quarter why is the economy shrinking
well no surprises it's to do with
consumer spending and behind that story
is a story about consumer confidence
look at how how anxious UK consumers are
that's the Blue Line compared to some of
our peer economies in the G7 while
everyone is feeling the cost of living
crisis UK households are feeling it
worst of all a combination of rising
Energy prices rising cost of food and
fuel and of course the ongoing effects
of those difficult inflation and
interest rate numbers
the effect of that downturn in consumer
sentiment is being felt at the tills if
we have a look at what people are
spending their money on today we can see
the essential spending is up now of
course that is a function of the fact
that inflation is 10 so we're not
spending Less on Essentials we're
spending more because everything costs
more
thing that consumers can delay spending
money on they are delaying spending
money on the only little glimpse of good
news is that our spending in pubs and
restaurants is holding up for the time
being let's hope that England and Wales
do well in Qatar at least for the
landlords now unfortunately the effect
on the supermarket shopping checkouts of
all of this negative sentiment is that
while we're spending more that essential
spending Rising year on year
we're getting less for our money you can
see the jaws of this crocodile are
opening as while the amount that we
spend on everything from potatoes to to
lettuce increases the number of those
items in our food baskets decrease we're
spending more and we're getting less for
our money put this picture together and
looking forward it's not a pretty
picture the bank of England's
expectations now is for one of the worst
recessions on record while if interest
rates stay at three percent this could
be over as early as 2024 unfortunately
with interest rates set to rise as high
as five percent next year we're going
we're in line for the worst recession
potentially the longest recession in a
hundred years before things finally
start to improve more than two years
from now not a pretty picture for Rishi
sunak and Jeremy Hunt as they prepare
their statement